foreign
Regina is up next in San Antonio Regina
welcome to the show
hi thanks so much for taking my call I
appreciate it absolutely here's my quick
question well let me say quick and
here's my question what do you do when
you can't pay the minimums that's the
bottom line question my four walls are
up and everything else is done but I
just can't get to all of the debts with
the minimums um do I just let them keep
calling and just keep answering them and
tell them I'll get to them when I can do
I try to negotiate the minimums what do
I do well number one you're doing a
great step in just proactively
communicating with them and letting them
know hey here's where I'm at here's the
bills here's the order on paint them in
here's how much I can give you this
month
and if you do that it's better than you
ignoring the calls and it going to
collections and have people coming after
you I want you calling them more than
they call you
okay so what are these payments
how many do you have
um uh there are
um
several of them
um they total up to 555 778 555
000
is this all personal debt
um personal pretty much personal debt
does that include your mortgage yeah no
that does not include a mortgage and
there's a there's some land in there
there's
um there's um credit cards
um what are the big chunks how did you
get a million dollars a million bucks in
a debt Regina what happened
just a whole lot of a little bit of
everything you know you you stop paying
attention and you just you know you just
kind of keep going you make good money
and you think that you're invincible and
here and one day you turn around and
that's where you are what's your
household income
uh 200 okay and is it just you is there
a spouse
yeah my uh yeah I have a spouse okay
and how much of this is kind of the
Consumer Debt outside of the land
what kind of data are we talking
um we're still at four because the land
is only 100. okay so what's the rest of
the four I'm confused here is student
loans credit cards car payments
student loans credit cards medical bills
personal loans
uh yep medical bills personal loans yep
yep I'm running out of things to even
throw out there Regina I mean if you you
have them and that's really all but
they're just a lot of what's the biggest
what's the big ones like how much credit
card debt are we talking
um the credit card debt is uh fifty
thousand
um personal the the Consumer loans are
probably the biggest ones those are
uh in the 150 range what was that for
what did you buy
just a whole lot of stuff like stuff for
the house what are we talking I don't I
don't like if you gave me a half million
dollars I don't know that I'd have
enough ideas to spend it like that
so I'm just I have a dark curiosity at
this point
a lot of a lot of stupid stuff okay so
are is your husband on the same page
that you guys are going to get intense
about this and go scorched Earth and
live like broke people because you are
broke people
no he's not on the same page what does
he want to do no
um file for bankruptcy
and he just resigned to go let's just
keep going to dead it's fine when we
have to go bankrupt we'll go bankrupt
and start over
yep
oh Regina
Regina don't do that
I'm not definitely well we need both
parties involved to be on the same page
because you can't do this alone
what do you what do y'all do for a
living
I'm in banking and I.T
so you know what declaring bankruptcy
does to marriages
individuals like you absolutely I mean
your your lives are going to be a living
hell for the next decade if you do this
they're not going to be because we're
not filing that's not good
all right um I'll tell you what you can
do you're gonna sell everything that you
can sell everything
Bye Felicia the crap that you bought
with the credit cards is getting sold
goodbye all of it all of it
we are we're working on it um so if you
sold everything you can sell what would
that add up to out of the 555
um if we sold everything that we could
then we're probably
[Music]
about let's see the line is one
cars sell them your Camry people these
are nice cars I imagine yeah no no we
don't what's your house worth
uh our house is worth five uh 580. and
what do you owe on that
uh four
okay
so if we downsized
we could clear 180 and get something
smaller right or even rent for a while
for a while
here's what we're trying to
um and I know you know this but I just
want to say it clear
y'all are in a desperate situation
y'all make a lot of money which is good
you'll make a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year it's great
but y'all are broke broke broke and
you're you're one illness away you're
one layoff away from this whole house of
cards coming down on you and I know you
know that right you feel it yep
absolutely so have you sat down with
your husband and said honey
I can't breathe
I'm scared to death
and I'm not going to be a per I'm not
going to file bankruptcy because it's
not that's not Integris we have the
money we're just choosing to not live
this life because here's the deal y'all
are going to file bankruptcy and y'all
gonna run this thing right back up
because you all have not changed the
core issue which is y'all don't have a
plan y'all aren't together on the same
page and you don't have the discipline
that that getting out of this thing
together is going to give you
do you guys have kids
uh they're old we're in empty nesters
okay
how old are you two
um in our 50s
and when do you plan on retiring
um well at this rate never never yeah
ever well here's the deal I have a lot
of hope that the situation can turn
around and it can actually turn around
pretty quickly because it's really quick
huge shovel
because if you sell the house that's
you're going to get 180 there if you
sell everything else you could probably
clear another 200 right
yeah for sure so that's already 380 out
of the 555. and now making 200 we're
throwing 100 at the deck because we're
living on nothing and all of a sudden
we're debt free in a couple years
right so bankruptcy doesn't make sense
when it's that clear of a path
but he has to get on the same page and I
can I can give you a tool to help you
get there I can't force him and that
tool is going to be Financial Peace
University so I'm going to give that to
you do you think he'd go through that
with you all nine lessons getting on a
budget I've already tried I used to
teach it 10 years ago why doesn't he
want to do it
no he doesn't why
he thinks there's nothing new to learn
is he not looking at the in the mirror
or at the bank statement what
yeah
Hey listen he's not on the phone so we
can't there's no sense in in going after
him what I would tell you is for the
first time in a long time in your
marriage
I would let him know how terrified you
are
and let him know I'm not interested in
signing off on bankruptcy papers we make
enough money we can be debt free in a
couple of years we got to change our
life
you guys are gonna need counseling yes
if he's not willing to do this because
there's a lot deeper issues I'm still
going to gift you Financial Peace
University because I have hope for you
guys but man this is a big situation and
counseling is a lot cheaper than divorce
I'll tell you that much so I really
really hope this all works out please
call us back if you need any help we are
here for you Regina